today I'm going to be reviewing the pan
toast technology ico pan tous is the
first multi block chain token system and
Before we jump into the specifics let's
make sure we're sort of all on the same
page here I SEOs of course are the
crypto currency equivalents of IPOs in
an IPO a company makes their initial
offering of shares to the market in an
IC o----
a new project makes the initial offering
of their underlying crypto token now I
want to be super clear as I've been
before that I'm not giving any
investment advice here on the channel
I'm not suggesting anyone on the basis
of my review invest in this or in any
other IC o---- I'm not even assessing
the monetary potential of the coin here
this is a review of the platform the
problem it looks to solve which in the
case of pantos technology is a big big
problem super interesting one because
that's something we can actually assess
and I'm not doing nor do I follow any
technical analysis I'm not a day trader
I'm not really a trader at all in this
space and anyone who's been following me
for years knows my investment philosophy
and in stock markets and mutual funds
it's buy and hold on the basis of the
long-term fundamentals and the value of
what you're investing in it could be an
individual company's shares of stock
when you're investing in a country's
bonds you're sort of investing in a
country all the same logic applies to
icos and crypto currencies so my
analysis is going to focus on the
problem the project looks to solve what
are the use cases for it as well as the
underlying technology again to the
degree that I understand it and I'll
also look at the team that's behind the
project and community is a really big
deal here community for a lot of these
projects the community that's built
around the project can make or break its
success so here's the setup right now
there's huge competition between
projects in blockchain and crypto and
the whole world of crypto is very very
fragmented and people email me and they
express that and that's part of their
hesitation to even get involved in the
first place
and this fragmentation is partially
because of the desire
from projects to scoop up funding and to
acquire a user base and what ends up
happening is that these crypto block
chains are effectively siloed and it
makes interaction between projects very
very limited and big picture over the
long term that's probably going to slow
down blockchain adoption so the big
thing with the pentose project is
cross-chain token transfers period full
stop right right now moving tokens from
one blockchain to another is virtually
impossible and pantos will bring
different crypto projects together the
goal being a situation where there's
more and better collaboration and
synergy between block chains and that
will allow the transfer of the same
asset between block chains using what
are known as atomic swaps that's sort of
the macro of the situation and there are
also some micro issues to talk about
there's demand for crypto transactions
at least on some block chains to happen
more quickly and part of the impetus for
this is to avoid people spending much
time converting coins in order to
participate in transactions or projects
with people who are using different
types of coins pantos will support in
its first generation Bitcoin aetherium
waves comodo liske and nem nem the goal
is ambitious right to speed up use so
much that it will actually create an
advantage for people using pantos over
those not using it's a major major goal
team-wise and sort of knowledge-wise
pantos is partnered with the Technical
University of Vienna and that's
specifically for the token atomic swap
technology known as tasked project this
is going to be a joint project
specifically set up to monitor the
introduction of this atomic swap
technology into the pan toss project
they're big players as far as the team
goes our Paul clan shack who's
founder CEO of bit panda he's been
involved in crypto since 2011 he's been
involved in a number of different crypto
projects Erik DeMuth co-founder CEO of
bit Panda serial entrepreneur in the
tech world for a long time now and
Christian trummer CTO of bit panda
another serial entrepreneur also the
author of efficient web programming bit
panda has been in the crypto game for
years now and is a pretty well-known
entity it's Europe's leading retail
exchange for a number of crypto
currencies and something that
distinguishes pantos from many other
projects is that some of the key people
are known entities right there they're
also partnered with known and respected
projects like liske Komodo and waves the
token will be pan PA n total supply is
going to be a billion tokens 40% of
which will be allocated to the ICO
participants 59% will be in a company
reserve that'll be for future
fundraising management and employees and
then 1% will be air-dropped to eligible
bit panda users and that gets us to
technology inherently if this project
succeeds the scale of the community that
could be built is going to be huge just
by its very nature because the whole
idea is instead of having these siloed
crypto communities based on the token
Metzen use by the project this is going
to open the doors for the communities
that would previously be totally
isolated to actually become one larger
community so the big picture goal here
is not only admirable and interesting
it's potentially a game changer it's
also a gigantic goal right creating
interoperability between blockchains so
if there's a risk here it's that this is
a major major undertaking and the
success of it is just not guaranteed
until it happens you can learn more
about the project yourself at pantos io
that's P a and T OSA oh and you can use
the links in the video description